well
this is the last half of the day and
it's my first 1am talk
uh so yeah thank you very much for
giving these this talk so yamas
he's from iced austria
so the floor is yours yeah
okay thank you very much um yeah thanks
a lot for the kind invitation
uh it's really a pleasure to speak at
this
very nice
an interesting program
um
okay so i will
um continue kind of the story of today
which is about optimal transport
um
and my talk well of course built on some
of the previous talks by michaela and
also by marco
and what i will focus on mainly in this
talk is uh uh sort of the additional
difficulties and challenges which arise
if you
uh
try to uh to uh apply some ideas from
optimal transport in the listening of
discrete systems and also a little bit
about what happens if you try to
apply these ideas in quantum settings
okay
but kind of the starting point of my
story will
overlap a bit with what we've seen
before
this is kind of the circle of ideas
about
connecting optimal transport
to on the one hand sort of pdes in
particular diffusion equations
and in another direction also to
geometry and in particular to rigid
curvature
and i think that's something that that
we didn't see so much yet during this
this workshop so that's also something i
would like to talk
talk about
okay so um
to keep the talk a little bit
self-contained here's once again the the
optimal transport problem which we by
now saw many times this week
um so you're given to probability
measures and you want to transport
uh mass from one configuration to the
other
so a natural setup i mean if you want to
do this in great generality is to work
in in the metric space
so i take two probability measures mu
and nu on a metric space x
and then the important concept is that
of a transport plan or a coupling
between those two measures
which is just a probability measure um
with marginals mu and u so if i project
them to the first formula to get mu
and if i project onto the second
coordinate i get i get new
and then the optimal transfer problem
that won't come through which problem
that we saw many times
as the following you would like to
minimize the total transport cost so the
integral of the cost function
c
[Music]
you want to minimize with respect to
overall couplings overall transport
plans connecting these two
uh probability measures
okay and
then um
well what we already saw in mikhaila's
lecture is that there is a very
beautiful connection to uh to pds to the
fusion equations
um which goes back to the work of jordan
kindler otto at the end of the 1990s
and this involves a very particular
optimal transport problem namely the one
where the cost function is the square of
the distance which corresponds to the to
the so-called waterstein or counter of
which metric
on probability measures so this is the
optimal transport problem with the
quadratic cost function
then the second
main actor in the story is the entropy
or the negative of the of the boltzmann
shannon entropy so for probability
measure mu
with density rho
with respect to the lab measure the
enthalpy is the integral of rho log rho
dx
well in the first the third object is
the diffusion equation or the heat
equation
which you can regard as an as an
evolutionary equation in the space of
probability measures
and then the beautiful results
connecting those three
um is this theorem by jordan kinder leo
and otto which is that the heat flow is
the gradient flow of the entropy
with respect to this vasospine metric
from optimal transport
so intuitively speaking it's the
steepest descent
so the the diffusion equation is exactly
the evolution equation
which tries to uh to decrease the
entropy
uh in such but in such a way that you
don't move too much with respect to the
muscle style metric
okay we already saw this before we also
see tomorrow but let me let let me give
you one way to look at this result so
you can actually interpret it at various
different different levels
but i will tell you one way how to do it
so here's once again the statement of
the theorem the heat flows the gradient
flow of the entropy with respect to not
metric on available measures
defines a metric but you don't really
have a
at least not immediately you don't have
a riemannian structure so it's not very
obvious how you make sense of such a
concept
and um well there are different ways to
do it
but one of them i can explain
in three lines on this slide
and to see what's going on it's
instructive to look
at the simplest possible setting and
mainly at gradient flows in rn
so if i'm in euclidean space rn
and if i have a smooth and convex
functional
then
there's actually a very very nice
description of gradient flows mainly if
i have a curve a curve u
in in in space
rn
then the following are equivalent
so the first condition is that u
um
solves the gradient flow equation
so it means that it solves this ordinary
differential equation u prime
equals minus gradient of phi of u so
that's the usual
um
differential equation which means that
this curve is the gradient flow
uh for the functional phi
but you can do something uh something
nice maybe because there are functional
phi is complex
you can actually rewrite this
differential equation as a system of
inequalities
um just by by using the variational
formulation for the for the gradient of
a complex function
so it's sort of
um
yeah just the
tangent line description of the gradient
of a
convex function you see that this
gradient flow equation is actually
equivalent to this system of
inequalities
since the function was convex
but now what you can do is if you look
at the left-hand side of this expression
is you can actually rewrite this
maybe you can write this as the
derivative
of the square distance between u t and y
and just by applying chain rule you see
that these are the same objects
now you've there's something interesting
namely the uh
if you look at the second
inequality
you actually see that it makes sense in
great generality because there's no
gradient of phi appearing anymore
and also the derivative of u that we saw
in part one is not present in in part
two
right because we have here
uh the derivative of a scalar quantity
namely the square of the distance
so the second formulation is completely
equivalent to the first one
but it has the great advantage that it
makes sense actually in metric spaces
okay because the only thing which you
need
to to have in order to formulate this uh
this the system of inequalities is you
need to have a distance
for the left-hand side and you need to
have the functional
and so this uh this system of
inequalities actually characterizes
gradient flows at least in the presence
of some convexity and you can actually
take this as a definition of gradient
flow in the metric space
and now one way sort of going back to uh
to this uh theorem by jordan kindler
alto so one way to make regular sense of
this theorem is actually
by actually transferring this
formulation also to the
sustained space
so you have a solution or a curve of
measure satisfies the heat equation
if and only if it satisfies the same
evolution variational inequality
as we saw below
but now with euclidean distance replaced
by this waserstein 2 metric
and
and the role of phi is now taken over by
the enthalpy
so this is a metric formulation of the
of the gradient flow
uh structure for the for the entropy in
the laser sten space
okay well this result doesn't i mean it
doesn't stand on its own i mean they're
actually many um many extensions of this
of this theorem has been very
influential so this applies to extremely
general spaces it's been extended to
romanian manifolds
to infinite dimensional spaces like
hilbert spaces vienna spaces
um to sub romanian spaces like
heisenberg group alexander of spaces so
very non-smooth
objects
and sort of this line of research kind
of culminated in the work by ambrose
chili savaday who actually made sense of
this
this gradient flow formulation in
setting of metric measure spaces
and so in full generality they showed
that
sort of the
the heat flow which you can define
as the gradient flow for the dirichlet
energy and l2
coincides with the gradient fills the
entropy in the mass of state space
okay
well you might ask the question actually
why would you do this because of course
the
uh the diffusion equation is one of the
simplest
pdes it's a linear equation so why would
you write it as a as a complicated uh
evolution equation in this in this
non-linear fashion
well there are actually good reasons for
that so um one of them is that it does
not only apply to the diffusion equation
but it actually works for a very large
class of
dissipative equations like for
compliance horse medium mckinflas of
equations
um
it's physically appealing it also
connects to probability to large
deviations
it comes with good time discrete
approximation schemes i think a gradient
flow structure gives you a kind of a
natural way to to write the time
discretization
and also it applies to non-smooth
problems as you saw before it applies to
very general
situations
it gives you interesting inequalities
and estimates
so functional inequalities
connecting various quantities like
entropy fissure information
and passage time metric
and it also gives
information about speed of convergence
to equilibrium
uh for instance for for uh of course
medium equations
and finally another advantage is that
this formulation is actually closely
connected to
geometry and in particular to richie
curvature
so i would like to say a little bit more
about this this geometry
connection
okay so and well before
making this more formal
um let's look first at this uh this
cartoon
uh which is supposed to describe this
this thought experiment uh which uh
cedric villani in his book called the
lazy gas experiment
and the idea here is that
you would like to um
so suppose that you're on on a manifold
like on this sphere drawn below
and you would like to understand um
whether you're on a positively curved
space or a negatively curved space or on
a flat space
but you don't want to compute like
curvature tensors and things like this
so you want to have a more robust
approach
and the way to do it is by the following
experiments
so
you take
a gas
living on this manifold so a cloud of
particles
and at time zero
you force your particles to be located
in this little green area at the left i
don't see though if you see my curves
are moving
yes
okay very good
okay so that's the co so that's the
cloud of particles at time zero located
over here another times time one
you ask your particles to be located
into this green area over here
but your your particles are lazy
so they want to spend as little energy
as they can
so they're going to travel along shorter
spots
and of course on manifold the shortest
path is not a straight line
but it's a it's a geodesic
and now you see uh i mean you said drawn
in the picture what happens in the
presence of positive curvature so if
you're on the sphere what happens that
initially your geodesics tend to spread
out
um so they diverge and then at the end
they they converge again
and so if you look at
where your cloud of particle is at at
the midpoint
you see actually that they're in this
red area over here and they're actually
much more
diffuse than at the boundary points so
the mass is much more spread out
okay what you do is you keep track of
the entropy along this interpolation
so if i talk about entropy i mean
actually relative entropy with respect
to the volume measure so the integral of
rho log rho
so not minus
roll up row like physicists would
put it
but if you keep track of the entropy
well what does the entropy measure it
measures how spread out my mass is
so in particular at the midpoint my mass
is much more spread out means that the
enthalpy or the relative entropy with
respect to the volume measure will be
lower
so if i draw the graph of the entropy
you see that you get this this convex
profile
so what you learn from this from this
experiment is that the positive
curvature of the sphere
is actually strongly connected to this
complexity of the entropy along this
interpolation
okay so and you can turn this
this idea into into mathematics there's
a long story behind this
um but this really started with the work
by by rob mccann in 94
so what he showed is that if you um
if you do this not on the manifold but
just on flat space just in rn
then what they proved is that the
entropy
is actually convex
along geodesics in the western space of
probability measures
so the entropy is is a convex function
of
a long linear interpolation just because
row log rho is convex in rho
but it's also convex along along this
western interpolation which is a very
different different
thing okay and then after this this
result got extended uh
to rimani and manifolds
um in a series of works
and there the statement is that for
riemannian manifold m the following
insertions are equivalent
only firstly that the rigid curvature of
your manifold is bounded from below by
uh by kappa where kappa is just a scalar
scalar constant
so if you don't know what richie
character is it doesn't matter for this
for this presentation very much but it's
one
important concept of curvature
and this condition is equivalent to this
to the convexity of the entropy
or
more precisely the capacity of the
entropy
along geodesics in the water's tanks
based on your manifold
this copper convexity means that you
have the convexity of the enthalpy
minus some correction
involving your constant kappa coming
from the curvature
and the muscle's diametric
okay so this is a
this is a beautiful characterization of
this lower bound on the richie curvature
and
just like we have in this gradient flow
characterization the interesting thing
here is that the second part is much
more robust to the first part
because to be able to talk about ritchie
curvature
you need to define the rigid tensor for
which you need to have a
smooth romanian structure
but to make sense of the second
[Music]
condition you actually need much less
structure right because you need to be
able to talk about the entropy
for which you need to have a reference
measure
and you need to be able to talk about
muscle's time metric and for this you
need to have a distance
so this actually makes sense in in
metric spaces and that with a measure so
this was the
the starting point of a of a theory of
of lower richie curvature bounds in
metric measure spaces uh initiated by a
lot storm and villainy
so you don't directly make sense of a
rigid tensor but you you can actually
make sense of a lower bound on the rigid
curvature without really defining the
rigid parameter itself
and that's uh i mean already having this
lower bound is kind of a crucial crucial
thing in many applications
okay so here's that this is written as a
definition
um oh this is what i just said so a
metric measure space
uh xdm satisfies this lower bound on the
rigid curvature
um if this convex inequality for the
entropy holds
along all geodesics in the massage time
space of probability measures
so where does them show up
uh yeah so m shows up in the entropy so
it's the entropy actually the rate of
entropy with respect to the reference
measure m
okay
yeah thanks for the question
yeah so the enter the m shows up on the
end for p and the d shows up in the
buses time matrix
okay so this is the starting point for
our ritz theory uh
it's uh the important points are that
this applies to a white class of metric
measure spaces
without necessarily having a smooth
structure
um it gives you many interesting
consequences
um so here are a bunch of uh
inequalities uh noted so sobolev
telegram and poncare inequalities it's
also connected to concentration of
measure uh inequalities
and many other things
and also it's stable yeah so it's stable
under passing to the limit of uh
in
of your metric measure spaces so it's
stable under the notion of measured
grommet house of convergence
so there is now a rich theory
of optimal transport in this in this
very general setting
and this has become a very active
research area
okay so this is extremely general
um but let's now move back and and ask
what happens if we uh if we try to
apply these ideas to the setting of
discrete spaces
okay and to get a feeling for what's
going on let's do something extremely
basic
let's look at the simplest space we can
imagine
which is the two point space
so just
two points zero and one
well of course in the two-point space we
can have we can write every measure um
for every probability measure as a
convex combination of two dirac masses
so mu alpha is the measure with mass one
minus alpha at zero
and mass alpha at one
okay let's now see what what actually
this voltage time metric
looks like in this context
well if i compute this buster's time two
metric
between
mu alpha and new beta
well what you get is the following you
get the square root
of the absolute value of alpha minus
beta
because you get the distance square
which is which is equal to one
times the the amount of mass that you're
transporting which is alpha minus beta
and at the end of this definition of
plusest time you take the square root
because it's muscle stem too
okay so um
so this is the western style metric on
on this two point space and let's now
see what we can say about geodesics so
suppose that they have a geodesic in the
space of probability measures which i
can write as mu of alpha t
but what does it need to be a constant
speed geodesic
it means that the
distance between the measure at time t
and the measure at time s
is proportional to t minus s
right
but but by what we just saw
is that this voltage time metric is also
equal to the square root of alpha t
minus alpha s
and if you now stare at this
this identity and compare the left to
the right hand side
then you see that it means that actually
alpha must be whole or continuous
without our exponent two
but of course this cannot be
unless the curve is actually constant
so what this
simple computation show
is actually that there do not exist any
non-trivial geodesics in the vaster
stands space but it's two-point space
every geodesic is constant
and that's not a coincidence because you
can actually show
that
the wasserstein space of probability
measures with respect to this business
type 2 metric
is a geodesic space
if and only if the underlying space
is geodesic
that's it means as a geodetic space is a
perfect which is a space in which you
can connect every pair of points by a
constant speed q does it
so what this basically tells you is that
if you started with discrete space
um and you look at the buses time space
so there was this time 2 space over this
discrete space you will not find any
geodesics
and that's bad news because it means
that what i told you before actually
does not apply
uh maybe you will not find any curve for
finite lengths
um so you don't find any geodesic so you
cannot talk about you there's a
connection with the entropy
and you can also not find any curve of
finite length so you cannot find any
gradient flow in the space of
probability values and that's what this
was stand to metric
so this uh this story before is
extremely general it applies to very
general uh metric spaces
but it uh when it breaks down if you try
to apply it directly in a discrete set
okay so let's uh um let's see what we
can do nevertheless because that turns
out that there is uh
there's a way to get around these
difficulties
um
so let me start with writing down the
discrete uh setting that we that we look
of look at
so the starting point uh
is that you you take a discrete discrete
set so let's just take a finite set of
points x
and then you can uh
it's natural to take as a starting point
l to be the generator of a markov chain
which you can write in this form
so l of psi is like a discrete laplacian
like written over here where qr the
transition is q x y is the transition
rates
um
between x and y
or equivalently you can start with a
[Music]
with a graph
or a weighted graph
okay so about by
sort of
standard markov chain theory if i take
an irreducible markov chain
or in other words if the associated
graph is connected
there exists a unique invariant
probability distribution let's call this
pi
and of course there's a natural entropy
in this in this context which is just a
relative entropy
of a measure mu with respect to pi
right just
the same as we saw before but now
there's no integral but they're just the
sum
another question that that's kind of is
natural in the view of this uh this
gradient flow description of the
diffusion equation is
is the the kolmogorov forward equation
sort of
uh if you want the discrete heat
equation
associated to this markov chain sort of
the flow of probability measures which
describes the evolution of the
of the law of your markov chain is this
a gradient flow of the relative enthalpy
with respect to some metric on the space
of probability measures
so this would be the direct analog of
this jko theorem
what we saw in the previous slide is
that
this is uh not going to work if you take
maybe the first attempt maybe if you
take boston's time too
because um i argue that there do not
exist any
gradient flows in this
in this boston stein space of
of exposure too
uh nevertheless you can try to solve
this problem on the two point space and
if you do that on two point space here's
the answer
so you can indeed find the metric on
probability measures and it's given by
this by this strange formula
involving some
hyperbolic arc tangent
so probably not not the first
metric you would you would try
if i would ask you to guess
okay um
so the question is of course where does
this come from um and can we make sense
of this also uh in a little bit more
interesting discrete settings maybe on
arbitrary discrete spaces
so this can be done
and to do that it's again instructive
to look at the continuous setting
so let's go back to our n
and let's look at this dynamical
characterization of w2 that also uh
mikhail already presented
however you change a little bit the
point of view instead of looking for
optimal couplings between two
probability measures
you're trying to find
a curve in the space of probability
measures
so continuous time interpolation
connecting two given densities
so if you start with row naught and row
one you're connecting them in continuous
time
by a curve of measures
okay then what you want to do is you
want to regard again your your measure
as a cloud of particles
and you want the tracks of the
trajectory of each of your particles
and there is a velocity vector field
which describes the movement of these
these individual particles
and the velocity vector field that
denote by psi
okay and here's this uh
the venomous formula
that we saw this uh
this morning
um
and uh well this gives a dynamical
formulation of the muscle style metric
um
in terms of this continuous time
optimization problem
um
and it tells you that you can actually
uh compute the min the muscles time
distance by minimizing the total kinetic
energy so so the square of the i mean
this is the square of the velocity
vector field
integrated against the mass so this is
really a kinetic energy integrated in
time
and you minimize among all curves of
probability measures connecting your
given boundary measures
so this is the formula due to uh to
banimoo and 208
from 2000.
okay so this is an important theorem in
in continuous optimal transport
um
maybe as a
just one comment you can actually assume
without loss of generality that your
your vector field is uh
is a gradient
because the optimizers will always be
gradient vector fields
uh modular some
technicalities that i would like to
sweep under the rock now
so we can always assume that that the
optimal vector field is actually a
gradient in this minimum quantity
formulation
okay so this is a theorem in the
continuous setting maybe the equivalence
between this discrete and sorry
equivalence between static and dynamical
optimal transport so
this metric to find in terms of the
one's control this problem is equivalent
to this dynamical optimization problem
so in the discrete setting this is no
longer true so there's no longer
equivalence between this dynamical and
statical picture of optimal transport
but it's sort of tempting now to uh to
try to do something similar in discrete
something so in the discrete setting
you uh you can you can also look at sort
of dynamical optimal transport problems
so here's once again the continuous
formulation
and here's now a sort of an attempt to
define an analog in the discrete setting
so we're in the setting of the alpha
x
and i would like to define this
dynamical optimal transport uh
problem
well and if you
try to do it well you can just try to
replace all the continuous objects with
their discrete counterparts right so the
well the time integral
stays the same
the integral in space
is replaced by a sum
um
immediate here in the continuous setting
you don't have on the graph right but
the next best thing is sort of this
discrete derivative
then here there's this lebec measure um
which will be uh replaced by sort of
some some data of your graph so the this
is this omega xy which
uh contains the transition rate of your
markov generator and invariant
distribution
but then there is something left open
here and in the continuous setting you
have the density
at time t
and so also here in the discrete setting
you would like to write
the probability
density
but now you see that there is some issue
because um in the continuous setting
you're actually
looking at the velocity vector field at
the point x and you multiply it by the
density at the same point x
but if you try to do it on a graph then
you see that this um
[Music]
this velocity or this this gradient is
actually not defined at a single point
but it's defined between two points
right it's defined on on an edge of your
graph
whereas your mass lives at the vertices
and so there's some some uh
ambiguity here so should you put here
uh rho t of x should you put your row t
of y
or should you put something different
so the problem is in some sense the must
depend on vertices but your your
gradient is defined on the edges of your
graph
okay and
well
what turns out to be
a natural thing and i will explain
on the next slide why is that you put
some function actually depending on the
density at x and the density at y so
this is your measure divided by the
reference measure so the density at x
density of y
and you take some average of these
densities
and of course you have some freedom to
choice your your favorite average so you
can take just the arithmetic mean
um or the geometric mean for instance
but what turns out to be very natural is
to take the logarithmic mean of these
densities which is defined by this
expression so the lower effect mean of a
and b
is defined by this
by this non-linear average
okay so this defines a sort of an analog
of this minimum grenier
and for the continuity equation you can
do something similar right so you
replace all the continuous objects by
their discrete counterparts
so the divergence is replaced by a
discrete divergence
but then you run into the same issue
that you want to multiply a density in a
vector field
and you resolve it i you resolve this
again by uh by putting here this
logarithmic mean
of two intensities
okay so this is a direct analog of bonus
question um
yeah
the very big mean of two densities is
the density
yes so what you do you do it point wise
so you at each at each vertex of your of
your graph
you take the logarithmic mean of the of
the density at that vertices vertex
um
but but but the lower ethnic mean is not
defined at the vertex right it's between
it's between two vertices so it's in
some sense it's an object which lives on
the edges i see
right and it's it's not normalized or so
yeah thanks
okay so you see that there's a natural
analogue of brennemu pj
but you have some additional freedom in
the discrete world because you can you
can play around with this mean
okay so what can we say about this about
this metric well the good news is that
it's actually much better we have than
this w-2
distance because this is actually a
distance
which is induced by a romanian metric on
the space of probability measures
so this is a romanian romanian distance
um
and the theorem which sort of uh
maybe justifies why we actually are
interested in this in this rather
complicated distance
is that it allows you to have a discrete
version of this jko theorem
so you can show that the discrete heat
flow or in other words this
discrete focal planck equation or
discrete common graph equation
in any case the flow of probability
measures given by the markov chain is
the gradient flow of the entropy with
respect to the
with respect to this distance on
on the space of probability
measures okay and this this result was
actually discovered uh
in in kind of different communities uh
it's like the different versions around
the same time
um
independently also by alexander milk in
the context of reaction diffusion
equations
and
by chao one li and zhu
in the context of
numerics for focal plunk equation
okay well i hope this sounds kind of
natural but of course the
the question is why does this
logarithmic mean um show up because
that's not at all um
canonical
um well here's some short explanation
so let's look again at the continuous
setting
so in the continuous setting if you want
to write the heat equation um as a
gradient flow what you want to do is you
want to write it as a continuity
equation not just as we saw in mikaela's
talk so you want to write this heat
equation into this form so
dt rho plus divergence wrote psi equals
0.
well this you can do
and this you can actually easily check
so if you plug in psi because minus the
gradient of log rho then you see that
you get exactly the equation
right because
rho times the gradient of log rho gives
you the gradient of rho
and then the divergence of the gradient
it's laplacian
okay so that's
kind of a trivial computation in the
continuous setting
but if you discretize it actually
breaks down
because what you're using here is
actually the chain rule
yeah to to relate the gradient of row to
the gradient of of log of row
yeah so that's that's that's the chain
rule but this chain rule will fail in a
discrete setting because discrete
derivatives don't satisfy a chain rule
okay so and to get around this
difficulty that's exactly why you use
the logarithmic mean
because this logarithmic mean
between row x and rho y
i wrote it down the previous slide as
this sort of is this
in this integral formulation
um
you can actually if you do the
computation you can actually see just
you can also write it as this difference
quotient so it's row x minus rho of y
divided by log of rho x minus log of rho
of y
so you can actually uh um
imagine hopefully that you can use it in
computations to uh
to sort of compensate for the lack of a
discrete chain rule at least for this
particular
log function and that's exactly what you
need if you want to prove this gradient
flow structure
okay
so that's the the discrete dynamical uh
transport metric which gives us now a
very nice
discrete version of this uh
result by jordan kinder auto
okay and then it's uh well in view of
this geometry which i which i talked
about before it's also natural then to
try to uh to use this idea also to talk
about
uh
richie curvature for discrete spaces so
rigid curvature for graphs or vector
curvature from markov chains
so you can now define given a markov
chain
with transition rates q and invariant
measure pi
you can say that it has a rigid
curvature bound from below
by kappa if the relative entropy is
kappa contacts along geodesics in this
reference to this optimal transport
metric
and these geodesics do exist because
this is really a riemannian
metric okay so here's just a list of
examples to show you that you can
actually compute this in uh in a bunch
of cases
um
so it uh in particular for the for the
discrete hypercube so it uh it behaves
well with respect to the dimension has
sort of the natural
natural tensorization property
and also for some for some simple models
of interacting particle systems you can
actually
compute this rigid curvature
but let me also mention that um
well this is kind of also an active
field of research trying to understand
curvature of discrete discrete objects
and this is by no means the only way to
define a notion of rigid curvature in a
discrete world um
and uh well it's actually not equivalent
uh to several other definitions so
another popular way to understand richie
curvature for graphs
um
is for instance introduced by jan
olivier
and this is based on
also an optimal transport
but it's based on contractivity of sort
of discrete heat semi groups with
respect to a busestein bomb metric
well i explained before that this buses
time 2 is not well behaved if you apply
it in discrete
spaces
but this bus time one metric is actually
much better
so you can use it
sorry it's just sound coming from
outside
sorry ah okay i thought i've had someone
answer some questions okay
so this was time one metric you can you
can actually also use to define a notion
of uh of curvature
but then this buses time one doesn't
work if you want to have a gradient flow
structure
okay so so for the gradient flow you
have to work with some kind of analog of
gel v2 as we used
yeah and
they're also the other notions of
curvature are sort of based on
macroemery curvature which is sort of a
calculus based on
on discrete gradients and
and and this quick laplacians which has
also been very powerful in continuous
settings and
which has also been sort of intensively
studied in in a discrete world
okay but one particular nice thing about
this uh
this kind of this notion of reticle
which are based on entropy and optimal
transport is actually that it allows you
to prove um kind of soul of type
inequalities in particular this kind of
discrete backgreamery type
theorem
so the formulation is that if you have a
reversible markov chain
um and kappa is strictly positive
then if the the richie curvature is
bounded from below by by the strictly
positive constant
then you actually have a lower earth mix
overlap inequality so this is this this
inequality relating
the relative entropy respect to the
stationary distribution
to some
to some other object which is
[Music]
well it's some analog of a fissure
information so some
functional rising information theory
and the constant in this inequality is
is given by the by the curvature of your
markov chain
and the interest in this kind of
functional inequalities is that they
actually imply
uh quantitative bounds on the rate of
convergence to equilibrium for your
markov chains so this implies
exponential decay of the relative
enthalpy
measured in this in this entropy
[Music]
yes expansion decay to random event for
p
with convergence rate kappa
so this uh this regis curvature can be
used to uh to say something useful about
speed of convergence
okay
um
yeah so let me also mention that sort of
this
um this discrete gradient flow structure
um
um actually has
sort of also sparked some
many sort of follow-up works um
and there are sort of various
interesting great inflow structures in
slightly different settings
so in particular it also applies i mean
you don't really need to have discrete
spaces but it applies also to to jump
processes or more general settings
like like lady processes for instance
um
it not only applies stuff to to kind of
linear
equation like this markov chains but
also to non-local interaction equations
on graphs and also to some nonlinear
pdes like discrete porous medium
equations
um
it also extends very natural
naturally to
chemical reaction networks
and so to chemical master equations
and the associated wheel equation
and it's also closely related to
to some
optimal transport metrics which uh arise
in the setting of the separate quantum
mechanics
uh which has also been studied by many
people in in recent years
um
and the idea is there that that
that you try to do optimal transport not
but not between probability
densities but optimal transport between
between density matrices so
positive definite matrices with trace
one
okay and i would like to say a few words
also on this uh
um on this non-commutative uh
version of optimal transport and so
optimal transport for density matrices
um
yeah and kind of the natural question
there is is again is there
some version of of the jko theorem so
this this great inflow structure
um
in the setting of the city of quantum
systems like for instance are studied in
quantum information theory
so let me give you sort of a one slide
introduction to to set a space to set a
stage
um
so we're interested in the dynamics of
open quantum systems
which are sort of uh well mathematically
they're sort of non-commutative
analogues of these markov
chains um
but they describe kind of physical
systems um
coupled to some to some heat path
um so the setup is that you you take a
hillboard space as usually in in uh in
quantum mechanics
and let's assume that that everything is
finite dimensional this will simplify
uh things a lot
but it's already very very non-trivial
and many essential ideas are present in
this setting already
so let's just take a finite dimensional
hilbert space
if you want just take the n by n
matrices
then some of the natural counterparts to
the uh to the probability densities are
these density matrices as i mentioned
before
so so this is the set of density
matrices all positive definite matrices
rho
um with trace one
so if you you can view this as a strict
extension of what we saw be what we did
before in a discrete setting if you
think about a discrete probability
density
um as some
diagonal matrix with with positive
entries something to one
then you see that you hear of something
similar but you actually allow sort of
matrices which are not necessarily
diagonal so you get objects which don't
necessarily commute with each other
okay so then it's also
natural to look at
what the analogues of markov summit
groups in this context
so these are semi groups now acting on
matrices
um
and
well
they are supposed to have the following
two properties well first of all that
should be trace preserving
and so the trace of of pt of rho
should be equal to the trace of of rho
and secondly they should also preserve
the the positivity of matrices and so if
you
take a positive definite matrix and you
uh have your semi group acting on it
then should again get a positive
definite matrix
and this complete positivity refers to
the to the fact that you want this
property also to be true
if you actually tensorize with an
identity matrix
so that's a technical assumption which
is which is important
okay so this is a well-studied
class of
systems in
[Music]
quantum mechanics quantum information
theory
in particular there's uh
there's a characterization of what these
what these generators for such objects
uh uh look like so the generator of such
a such a markov semi group or a quantum
mark of summer group
um it's given by this by this limb blood
formula
um
so you can write the generator in the
following form
it consists of two parts so the first
part is a commutator
we have some matrix h
that's this guy
and then there is like a second order
part if you want which is
a sum of of different terms
and they also invert involve commutators
of rho
um and a bunch of fixed matrices v
j so the precise form is maybe not
very crucial for the understanding of
this talk but in any case there is a
good
understanding of what these generators
um
look like
and they're in many ways sort of
analogous to generators of markov chains
okay so there's also a good good concept
of entropy so suppose that you have a
stationary state for such an evolution
equation so it means that
l of sigma
equals zero
then you can actually uh consider the
quantum relative entropy
so entropy rho with respect to sigma
it's given by the trace of rho log rho
minus rho log sigma
so this is a
uh to be understood in the sense of
of spectral theory so so row log rho is
a matrix
and you take the trace of this of this
matrix
yeah okay so this is uh this is the
natural yeah ask a question so uh i i i
know very little uh uh in the in quantum
like to just set concrete things is
there some notion of uh like ground
motion over this matrices or maybe it's
the equivalent of ornstein the lymphatic
process like when i think about a semi
group just to have like a concrete
example of what a
diffusion markov diffusion process would
be
do you have any concrete example of this
yeah yeah
all right yes actually actually orange
underback will come in i think in two or
three slides okay thank you um and there
there's there's also a concept of
brownie emotion related related to these
um to these objects so so these these
kind of objects are well studied
i will come back to arsenal back in a
few slides
okay so there's a natural notion of
entropy and um well it goes back also to
the 70s or so that
that you can
that this entropy is actually monotone
along the flow so the relative entropy
also in this quantum setting is actually
decreasing along the evolution of your
of your quantum markov semi group
okay so then it's natural to ask the to
ask the question actually uh
um
well it's written here can we now
formulate this this sort of
non-communicative analog of this markov
chain evolution this lymphatic equation
can we write it as a gradient flow
of the relative enthalpy
um
yeah
[Music]
okay so to uh understand this question
let's make some simplifying assumption
namely let's assume first
that uh our generator is actually
self-adjoint
yeah so it's uh and it's uh self-adjoint
with respect to this uh natural scalar
product on matrices given by this trace
of a star and b
and that's a symmetry assumption which
actually simplifies things quite a bit
okay then it's actually
known that you can actually write your
your generator
as a laplacian in the following sense
namely you can write your generator as a
sum
over j
of these uh well kind of derivatives but
they are not really the errors they're
actually commutators
so dj of a is the commutator of a with
respect to these operators vj that you
that we saw before
so the vjs are
are fixed matrices
um
and this dj dagger is actually the the
adjoint of dj
with respect to this trace duality
but the point is that you can really
write your generator as a laplacian
where you replace derivatives by
computations
okay and once you know this it's again
very natural
to play the same game as we did in the
discrete setup
maybe it's natural to define
uh an optimal transport distance a
dynamical optimal transport
uh distance on density matrices
by writing this binomial creator formula
so again i sort of um
well wrote something very similar to
what i wrote in the in the discrete
in a discrete setup
um with the difference that sort of
derivatives
or discrete derivatives are now replaced
by these operators dj which are
commutators
and i do the same thing here in this in
this kind of kinetic energy term
um the integral is replaced by the trace
as usual in the non-commutative setting
and for the continuity equation you do
something similar
okay but
again we see that there is a there is an
issue here
maybe just as in the discrete setup
where we couldn't really multiply things
which live on edges
with things which live on vertices
there's also some problem here if we try
to multiply things
right because
these objects are matrices
so uh multiplication does not
uh
it's non-commutative
so it actually matters whether we
multiply uh
well for instance row with this operator
from the left or from the right or
whether we do something different
so the question is basically how do you
actually make sense of this of this
product
so
i didn't specify what this what this fat
dot actually means
but but that's the question so how
what's the right way to define this this
multiplication in this in this
non-communicative
setup
and again what we actually need is we
need some version of this of this chain
rule
which was also a key ingredient to make
sense of this
of this
of the discrete gradient flow structure
so the question is that is there now
a non-commutative chain rule
basically for these commutators
okay and the good use is uh well there
is actually one and this can also be
shown on one slide
um so let's try to figure out what is
the right way to multiply here
um
we call it these operators dj they're
actually commutators which is matrices
vj
now commutators they satisfy lightness
rule
so we have this identity dj of a b is
dja times b
plus a times dj b
this you can of course iterate so if you
apply this
n times you find that the dj of a to the
power n
can be written in this in this form
okay
now what you can do is you can apply
this identity
to the matrix rho to the power one over
n so if i plug in rho to the power of
one over n here
i get d j of rho on the left hand side
and on the on on the right hand side i
replace a by rho to the one over m uh
three
times so you find this interesting
identity relating the derivative of of
rho
to the derivative
or this kind of commutator of this row
to the one brain
okay now these identity holds for every
n so it's very tempting to pass to the
limit
and then you recognize actually that the
right hand side you can view as a
riemann sum
so if you let n tend to infinity
what you find is that dj rho can be
written
as an integral from 0 to 1
of rho to the s
times dj of log rho
times rho to the 1 minus s
ds
so
if everything would commute it would be
just sort of saying that dj of rho is
equal to rho times dj of log rho
but now we found a particular sort of
non-commutative multiplication
uh which gave us this chain rule
now you see that it's very reminiscent
of what we had in the discrete
setup
um
where actually this logarithmic mean
appears so this is actually some kind of
non-commutative
version of this of this of this
logarithmic mean
okay so this suggests now the right way
to multiply and now here we can write
the written theorem
so suppose that i have this little belt
operator
so this generator of a quantum markov
semi group
with given operators bj
then i can define
an associated transport metric
so here i dropped again the same
bonus
type formula
as i did before so you minimize some
kind of analog of a kinetic energy
overall solutions to the continuity
equation connecting to given densities
or to given density matrices
um so this is the exact analogue of the
movement
but you replace your derivatives
by commutators
and we use this multiplication
given by this fat dot
um which is given by this
non-commutative logarithmic mean
okay and then the theorem is that if you
do that
so
remember we made this assumption of
self-adjointness with respect to trace
duality
then this this lymphatic equation
is actually the gradient flow of the
fundamental entropy
with respect to this this optimal
transport
metric
so in this sense
what this theorem tells you in some
sense is that this metric is actually a
natural replacement of this of this
vassenstein metric
but now acting on
in a non-commutative setting as a metric
between density matrices
okay um
yeah so i mentioned that we made sort of
the simplified assumption of of symmetry
so let me show you one
one slide i i'm not going through the uh
through the details but uh
you can pause the video on
on youtube if you want
so if you don't make this assumption but
if you assume that actually your your
generator is is uh
still self-adjoint but with respect to
some
non-trivial invariant uh state
then you can still obtain a gradient
flow structure which is sort of similar
in spirit but the algebra gets a little
bit more
more complicated but it extends to this
to this case as well
so we have a we have a gradient
structure
for a sort of
arbitrary dissipative quantum systems at
least in finite dimension
uh under this detailed balance condition
or the self-adjoinness condition with
respect to this
the scalar product
okay and um
yeah to come back to this to this
question
uh that was asked so an example
uh
sort of one of the simplest examples is
is a quantum version of the ornstein
underbex semi group
and so in the classical setup the person
the back semi group is kind of the
diffusion semi group
for which the stationary distribution is
the gaussian measure
and there's something similar in the
quantum quantum setup
but everything is defined in terms of in
terms of operators of course so the
starting point is that you take an
operator satisfying this this kind of
commutation uh relations
um which are called canonical
commutation relations
you can actually realize them concretely
on some on some
uh two space and that with the gaussian
measure
so the particular form is not not very
important but i wanted to write down
um
and then there's a natural analog of
quantum
of arsene wenbeck given by this given by
this formula
um
and that's exactly of this of this line
plot format that i showed you before
um
where actually these
these operators a and a a star appears
so these are the annihilation and the
creation operator for
a opposing quantum system
so this is a kind of a canonical uh
operator arising in in quantum
information theory um
it has a it has a gaussian array
stationary a gaussian stationary state
um
so in this sense it's also an analogue
of lubeck
and one of the things that
that we showed using these optimal
transport
ideas is some analog of this logarithmic
sobolev inequality
that i already showed
in the discrete setup
or in other words some some
exponential decay
of this quantum relative entropy
uh along the december group generated by
this quantum arsenal operator
and this is so this is some unlock of
the
of the logarithmic solar inequality
in this in this quantum setup
okay but if you try to obtain such a
result sort of by by direct methods then
it's it's actually not so easy in this
in this non-commutative setup because
computations get get very quickly kind
of out of hand
um
but this this optimal transport point of
view is is very fruitful because it it
gives you kind of some some structure
behind these computations and
um
we actually gave kind of a
relatively soft proof of this of this of
this result
and um
kind of the uh kind of uh
yeah i think which going to the proof
is um
well
very
kind of very algebraic uh thing so for
instance so some communication
property between the sami group
um
and these uh and these uh
uh these partial derivatives so these
commutators
um
so this is just an identity that you
that you can check
and the other thing which which goes
into this
these kind of proofs
is uh some complexity and equality for
uh
for matrices
which is given by this this formula
which looks maybe a bit complicated
um
but
so r and a are matrices
so r is positive definite and a is
arbitrary
so if those were scalars then the right
hand side would be a squared divided by
r
and a squared divided by r
is actually
a convex function jointly convex and a
and r
um
and also in this non-communicative
setting
this kind of object is a square divided
by r
um
is actually is actually a convex
function um
even if these objects are matrices which
don't
okay so um
so this is just an illustration that
with these optimal transport
methods you can actually
say something about
about these discrete systems about these
quantum systems
um
[Music]
in particular related to uh
concepts like entropy fischer
information and uh rates of convergence
to equilibrium for uh
um
well for mark of chains or for for this
quantum mark of sending books
okay um
yeah i think i'm sort of kind of uh
reaching the end of my time so maybe
this is a good good place to stop and
thank you for your attention
thank you for the very nice talk
is there other questions
so
so
this question may be related to the
question of
of philly
so is there a relation what do you serve
as your iranian motion
is it related to the semicircular
law so the semicircular law will have a
compact support
and your your brownian motion probably
will have non-compatible
so very related by the agent or
something like that
oh there is no relation
yeah okay so i mean you're right of
course that uh
uh
okay so another important setting in
this this non-commutative probability is
the setting of free probability um
[Music]
which sort of arises as a limiting case
of
random matrix theory
um
also optimal transport has been uh
analyzed and has been kind of been kind
of fruitful and resetting and actually
many of these inequalities have also
been obtained in in this context
um but some other setup is a bit
different and i don't know how to how to
directly relate to this kind of
dynamical point of view and density
matrices to the optimal transport in in
free probability
so i i so
yeah my understanding is that these are
two sort of different
non-commutative generalizations of a
classical object but they're
not directly
related to each other as far as i know
can you hear me
thank you can you hear me jan yeah so i
have a yes yeah
actually so the first one is uh uh if i
look at your lower bound on richie
curvature for the squid spaces
uh is there do you have some like you
know consistency guarantees for example
if i take a
smooth compact manifold i endow it with
the uniform measure
and then i just draw points uniformly at
random from it and i form some sort of a
nearest neighbor graph is there some
notion according to which
the
uh
nearest neighbor graph uh is going to be
uh to have its rishi curvature which is
lower bounded by something that tends to
the richie curvature lower bound for the
original manifold for example like there
are some results like this that just you
know just you know for example the the
lot stormvillani a lot of the work is to
check that this thing is consistent with
the manifold setting is there something
like this for your uh like having some
continuous objects for which you can
define the richie curvature as limits of
graphs
yeah that's a good question of course to
to to ask for some some consistency so i
think that the particular thing you're
you're asking is is maybe too much to
hope for so if you put sort of points in
a random fashion then then you're very
quickly you're going to destroy some
some bounce on the curvature
um so so if you want to preserve this
curvature at the discrete setting you
would actually
need to have some some rather kind of
well-structured kind of symmetric
uh symmetric settings
um but sort of the
passing to the limit in this in the
optimal transport problems that's also
something that has been uh studied uh
uh quite actively so for instance in the
setting of this random point cloud
there's
there's nights worked by uh uh nicola
garcia trios
who i believe is actually
i'm not sure where he is in berkeley i
thought i saw him on the video but that
was not yeah
yeah so so he has some very nice results
on convergence of this dynamical optimal
transport uh metrics to uh
uh to muscle style metrics in the
continuum for uh for random point clouds
so so there are some there are some good
convergence results in this
um in this respect
um
[Music]
but it's sort of if you if you start
with a continuous object and you you
sort of
um
yeah you you discretize with sort of
random points then i think you will not
you know not preserve the curvature um
so if you start with discrete objects
with with good curvature bounced then
the
the curvature should be preserved at the
limiting level that's i think that's the
direction in which things should be
better
so my second question is uh so when you
listed you know all the pros of having
this you know wasserstein gradient flow
interpretation of jko
uh you mentioned discretization in time
but somehow i feel that i mean the one
that i personally found the most
interesting in this discretization in
space and having this like deterministic
particle evolution interpretation of it
or you just push everything according to
optimal transport maps rather than like
diffusing along some random diffusion
that's like moving all over the place
and you know this is what you know
motivates all this svgd type of
approaches
one thing that i did not see
from your
formulation is do you actually get
deterministic velocities out of your
when you when you solve your problem so
you have this uh so you you say i want
to get an
equivalent
of jko for discrete spaces there's two
objects one is the entropy and the other
one is the wasserstein metric and rather
than i mean you could have said i want
to keep the vasterstein metric and i
want to move the i want to change the
functional but you decided to change
keep the functional and change the
vaster stein metric
is this vessel stein metric giving you
uh uh velocities when you actually solve
this like when you look at the gradient
flow would this tell me how to
deterministically evolve a particle so
that it's it's uh it's going to converge
to some distribution a system of
particles so that it's going to have
approximately limiting distribution pi
um
yeah so okay so i think you asked a few
things right so um
i mean it's true that i chose to to keep
the entropy and sort of i changed the
metric right so so if i would
um
i mean it depends on how you would
phrase the question right but but if you
would if you would want to stick with a
wasserstein 2 metric also in the
discrete setup then then there's no hope
to get a gradient flow okay because you
don't have any curves of finite length
so i think you have you have to i mean
you have to to do something kind of this
dynamical
inspiration dynamical optimal transport
um
so then um yeah the other thing that
just okay so do you get
um
okay so do you get philosophies for four
particles that's the other thing you
asked right
um
yeah so so um
not really i would say um
[Music]
okay because
um
yeah so so okay so so so this
discretization gives you kind of
evolutions of probability densities but
it it
it doesn't give you
like um
it doesn't say something about kind of
the motion of individual particles
and
actually these things might be a bit
counter-intuitive also because
um
okay so so for instance suppose that you
want to look at this discrete
dynamical transport metric like on the
um
[Music]
shaders on a triangle right so a very
simple discrete space just three part
three points and you have some mass at
one at one vertex or a direct at one
vertex you want to transport it to a
racket another vertex
then actually what will happen is that
some of the mass will actually will
actually go through the to the third
vertex
and so not all the mass will go through
the
to the
to the shortest path but actually some
of the mass
um
they'll go through the deferred uh
vertex that turns out to be cheaper than
doing everything on the on the uh
uh sort of the the path like what you
would think so so the optimal transport
actually might might um
uh yeah it might split so so it gives
you kind of sometimes a bit
counter-intuitive results and i don't
think you get
i mean i don't think you can uh it tells
you something about motion of individual
particles
i'd like just to comment a little bit on
that i you know overall i agree but
there is a you know a little bit of
something that saves you so namely uh
well what he wrote when you wrote down
young when you wrote down the venom
brainiac revelation you basically are
getting a non-local transportation of
graphs right so you have these potential
psi and psi j
and uh they are really telling you how
uh how is the mass being transferred on
a graph so if the particles are not
moving in this lagrangian setting that
they're moving but you know exactly
where is the mass moving so mass can
move along any two or along any edge as
long as actually in this case psi j
would be greater than psi i so when you
have the gradient flow you will still
have your potential which is uh you know
given by the logarithm of the
uh of mu right and you will be
transporting along those uh so your your
particles can split you know it can
actually be approximated by a markov
chain and these for some simpler
equations have done been done by uh
uh erbar vlados uh
and uh
fatih right in that paper so it can
there actually exist a genuine particle
approximation is but uh again instead of
the local transporter the no local
transport that can split particles but
you can still track where did the mass
go
and it you know for a heat it goes
approximately
up the or uh
yeah down the not down the non-local
gradient of the logarithm
but there's no unique choice to the path
that you have it's just telling you at
time t i have this this potentials on
labor this is a tank t plus dt i have
those and i can really do whatever i
want like if my particles have numbers i
can i can really just shuffle them any
way i want so i actually get this
potential next time
i don't understand what it means shuffle
do you still know where the mass is and
how it is being transported then you
know in the lemonade now you were
telling me i just know how much mass i
should have at the particular vertex at
rit how much mass i want at this vertex
or at any other vertex at time t plus dt
and then how i move the particles to get
from t to t plus dt is really up to me
no no you actually have potentials and
edges along which you transport so you
exactly transport along the edges as uh
using the continuous the null continuity
equation graphs that jan wrote when he
wrote out his venomous brainia
description so it's actually
deterministic the motion how the
particles go right there is a
deterministic dynamics even for the heat
equation
okay so that's what i was asking okay
right
okay so yeah that's right so you have
exactly that so the only thing that you
don't have you i mean in the continuous
setting you would write a different an
ordinary differential equation for your
for your particles
where the velocity is given by these
velocity vector fields right in the
discrete set up i don't think you can
write an ordinary differential equation
um
for this uh for this discrete velocity
vector
okay so another question yeah so in the
last slide we showed an lsi
kind of an inequality for
uh
the example that we showed with the
non-commutative group
uh does that imply also some sort of
concept
more
yes yes um
yeah yeah so okay so so i i showed this
kind of logarithmic software type
inequality
um
yes so okay so you can actually go
further and this logarithmic sublime
inequality it it implies some version of
of of telegram equality which actually
bounce this uh this wasn't time distance
in terms of the in terms of the entropy
and you can use this inequality to also
um
formulates some non-commutative analog
of concentration inequality so there has
been also work by data and jose in this
direction so so it is where it is
possible to turn this into some
concentration
statements in this non-community setup
yes
yes
um yeah is it possible to relate this
dynamical
transport distance on graphs to the
dysfunctional standard w2 distance up to
some error term which depends on the
discrete nature of the problem
uh
so to relate it to a
to a discrete w-2
yeah exactly on the graph
so the one that didn't work for um
yeah okay so okay so the the results
that
i know okay so what you can do is you
can you can actually
because if you do this on a graph then
you can actually obtain two-sided bounds
for it for this for this dynamical
transport metric so you can actually
bound from below by the wasserstein one
metric
where you actually take
passenger one with respect to the graph
distance
and you can bounce this dynamical metric
from above in terms of w2
where actually
you build your w2 using
kind of a distance between uh
a distance on the graph which you get by
sort of restricting your dynamical
transport metric to their to d rocks
so so you can sort of you can sort of
bound this from below but w1 you can
bound from the buffer w2
i
don't i yeah
i
i think it should be possible to get
error
error bounce there as well but uh
i haven't
i'm gonna directly point you to any
reference so this i'm not sure whether
anybody computed this
okay thank you
so yeah you mentioned in the beginning
like in the classical setting large
deviations
do you know like any analog equivalent
in the quantum case
ah that's also a natural question um
no
i think this is this is not understood
um
how these metrics relate to large
deviations in the quantity no i don't
think that
that there's any understanding there
yeah so let's see is there any other
question
so yeah thank you very much for staying
until late with us thank you for the
very nice talk
so i would thank you
all these speakers of the day again